[Musique]
quels sont les véhicules les plus
éco-responsables les meilleures voitures
électriques les surprises les déceptions
Benoît charrette et le rédacteur en chef
de la nouvelle de l'automobile il était
avec nous ce soir Benoît Charette
bonsoir salut 22e édition quand même de
la nouvelle de l'automobile c'est tout
un travail qui est là dedans il y a
énormément de données 22 ans plus tard
qu'est-ce que changer fondamentalement
l'automobile est en train de prendre un
virage électrique ça je pense que les
gens le réalisent et nous ça nous a
amené aussi à changer la formule du
livre cette année c'est à dire que
depuis quelques années les gens posaient
souvent la question avez-vous toutes les
véhicules électriques dans votre livre
avez-vous toutes les véhicules
électriques dans votre livre on les a
mais on les avait avec d'autres textes
c'est à dire que si on prend un modèle
comme le Hyundai Kona il y a un modèle à
essence et un modèle électrique on avait
un seul texte cette année ce qu'on a
fait il y a une section entièrement
électrique donc une section de véhicules
hybride rechargeable et à la session des
modèles à essence donc les gens vont
pouvoir aller dans la section qui les
intéressent et lire c'est parce que
l'avantage que ça offre c'est que le
véhicule électrique on a les
spécifications du modèle électrique un
texte sur le modèle électrique les
photos du modèle électrique donc là on a
vraiment je pense qu'on va claire à un
plus large public avec cette formule-là
même si on a tout ça il y a des délais
incroyables en ce moment les prix sont
élevés exactement ça ça reste comme ça
ça reste comme ça je dirais encore pour
au moins 2023 on voit un peu la lumière
au bout du tunnel à partir de 2024 le
problème c'est qu'en ce moment il y a
des mesures qui sont prises entre autres
pour les puces électroniques sauf que
les usines on doit un les bâtir et la
production doit commencer on a à peine
conclut des entorses pour construire
donc on est à bâtir sauf à qui aura pas
de production avant probablement
peut-être deux ans donc faudra attendre
ce moment-là les compagnies qui en
fabriquent en ce moment augmente au
mieux de leur capacité de la production
mais effectivement c'est encore assez
pénible je veux qu'on va y aller sous
forme de palmarès pour parler des
modèles le plus vendu au Canada ça reste
le fond de 150 absolument depuis 55 ans
donc c'est le modèle le plus populaire
on parle beaucoup de véhicules
électriques mais il faut pas oublier que
c'est au Québec en 12 et 13% de
véhicules électriques sont vendus ça
veut dire que l'autre 88 % ben c'est
encore des véhicules électriques il y a
un homme maintenant le F-150 Lightning
qui arrive au moment où on se parle les
premiers qui ont réservé on leur
véhicule depuis quelques mois donc on
calcule chez Ford ça va être à peu près
10% de la production des F-150 qui vont
être électriques considérant qu'on en
fabrique à peu près un million par année
là pour l'Amérique du Nord mais
considéré que c'est à peu près 100 000
par année
électrique la meilleure voiture
électrique vous dites que c'est le BMW
i4 très comme moi j'ai essayé c'est mon
opinion évidemment il y a beaucoup de
bons véhicules électriques mais la i4
moi ce que j'ai aimé de ce véhicule là
c'est qu'on arrive à avoir le même
sentiment de conduite sportive nerveuse
dynamique qu'on a du côté des produits à
essence mais dans un modèle électrique
donc je trouve qu'on perd pas à conduire
un véhicule électrique dans ce genre de
véhicule là alors que c'est pas toujours
vrai dans certains autres véhicules avec
une bonne autonomie quand même avec une
boîte 484 km donc un modèle extrêmement
plaisant à conduire la voiture la plus
éco-responsable on a mis la Mercedes
Benz ECB qui est toute nouvelle qui est
un bon qui est toute nouvelle en fait la
famille
Q chez Mercedes bon puis c'est sûr que
toutes les voitures électriques sont
éco-responsables mais il y a certaines
compagnies comme BMW qui vont par
exemple utiliser seulement que des
produits végétaux dans la fabrication
des sièges dans le rembourrage des
sièges on va aller chercher des bois qui
sont produits
qui poussent rapidement ou qui viennent
de forêt responsables donc on fait un
effort supplémentaire pour aller
chercher une vie un véhicule qui est
plus vert ça se fait du côté de BMW
également donc on aurait pu nommer
quelques compagnies mais chez Mercedes
là on a fait beaucoup on a fait beaucoup
d'états de ça dans les communiqués de
presse du côté de la compagnie quand on
dit plus éco-responsable les familles
avec des enfants puis faut rentrer
toutes sortes la poussette dans
l'automobile ça devient compliqué vous
dites que la plus éco-responsable quand
on a deux enfants c'est la Chevrolet
Bolt la chevrolete
pour la bonne raison que c'est un petit
véhicule le prix est intéressant si vous
regardez de savoir de 40 à 43 44000
dollars ça c'est avant les sub et je
trouve que pour les gens qui veulent pas
laisser une grande empreinte mais qui
ont une petite famille c'est un cas de
place si vous avez trois enfants il y en
a un trop pour ce véhicule là mais ça
demeure je trouve pour le prix un des
achats intéressants sur le marché la
plus agréable à conduire la Volkswagen
Golf GTI ah oui ben ça c'est une voiture
à mon goût on a gardé parce qu'on a
perdu la Golf de base qui n'existe plus
la Golf 8 et pas au Canada mais dans les
voitures polyvalentes agréables
confortable conduire tous les jours avec
plaisir dans les modèles que j'ai essayé
cette année c'est vraiment parmi les
trois plus intéressants que j'ai eu
l'occasion de conduire la surprise
la surprise il y en aurait quelques-unes
la GV la gv70 côté de chez Genesis
Genesis est assez nouveau dans le
segment des automobiles c'est tout neuf
mais cette voiture là on dit toujours à
la blague si tu arrives en retard à une
fête amène un cadeau à même quelque
chose pour te faire pardonner dans le
code jeunesse on a appris de ce qui
avait déjà sur le marché et on a bâti à
partir de ça ça donne un véhicule
extrêmement plaisant à conduire que les
gens m'apprécier et qui est moins cher
et moins ostentatoire que certains
modèles allemands le meilleur rapport
qualité prix la Chevrolet Bolt EV oui la
bande de base en fait est le véhicule
électrique le moins cher sur le marché
en ce moment
38198 dollars ça c'est le prix avant les
rabais provinciaux et fédéraux et là
évidemment on a eu certains retards
parce qu'on a du remplacer les piles d'à
peu près 140 mois de 140 000 modèles
donc mais ça demeure dollars pour plus
tard le véhicule électrique le plus
intéressant parce que vous avez 417 km
d'autonomie pour 30 quelques mille
dollars c'est pas plus cher pratiquement
qu'acheter une voiture à essence en ce
moment et une déception ouais la curé
était grave la cuin était grand est un
modèle dont on attendait beaucoup parce
que les gens qui ont connu la première
génération savent à quel point ce
véhicule là était nerveux dynamique
excitant à conduire et là on nous a
amené un mauvais remplacement d'un dos
civique ça manque de nerf ça manque de
cran il y a un modèle S probablement
c'est presque à venir dont on garde
certains espoirs mais ce modèle là était
un peu décevant pour beaucoup de
spécialistes tout est dans l'annuelle
donc de l'automobile 2023 Benoît
charrette merci beaucoup merci d'avoir
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI